Marvel Studios surprised everyone with the
announcement that Avengers: Endgame is getting
a re-release just two months after the film
hit theaters.
Marvel initially didn't say a whole lot about
the new version of Endgame, but now, the studio
has revealed what audiences will see up on
the big screen.
In a press release rolled out on June 25th,
Marvel detailed that things will kick off
with a video introduction from Avengers: Endgame
co-director Anthony Russo.
The film will then roll out just as it always
has, with no additional footage included.
Things get exciting after the credits roll,
though, when an "unfinished deleted scene"
plays out.
Marvel Studios didn't mention what happens
in the clip, but the folks at We Got This
Covered are claiming that it focuses on Mark
Ruffalo's Hulk.
As of now, it's unclear what the big green
guy will get up to in this never-before-seen
sequence, but we'd love to see Bruce Banner
working in his lab to combine his brains with
the brawn of the Hulk.
Similarly, Marvel didn't say anything in its
press release about a tribute, but we do know
that it's definitely coming, based on Feige's
past comments.
MCU Cosmic reports that the tribute is an
homage to none other than Stan Lee, the longtime
creative leader of Marvel Comics who helped
create several of our favorite superheroes.
Lee died at the age of 95 on November 12th,
2018, only a handful of months before the
theatrical debuts of Captain Marvel and Avengers:
Endgame.
It's a mystery what exactly the tribute entails,
but it seems likely that the clip will touch
on Lee's incredible contributions to the world
of comics.
Plus, it might even take a look back on the
many film cameos he made throughout the Marvel
Cinematic Universe.
An unfinished, scrapped sequence that apparently
centers on Hulk definitely sounds intriguing,
but it may disappoint fans who were hoping
to finally see the scene featuring Katherine
Langford as a teenage Morgan Stark.
The 13 Reasons Why actress was meant to appear
to Tony Stark in a vision after he uses the
Gauntlet and snaps his fingers.
On an episode of the podcast Happy, Sad, Confused,
Joe Russo stated that Tony would have seen
an older Morgan in the very same "metaphysical
way station" that Thanos went to after he
conducted his own snap in Avengers: Infinity
War.
"The intention was that his future daughter
— because these are the stones we're dealing
with, and they're magic — his future daughter
forgave him and sort of gave him peace to
go."
Right now, there's no way to know for sure
whether the deleted scene is all about Professor
Hulk or not, so there's a chance that this
scene could be the one shown during the Avengers:
Endgame re-release.
If it isn't, the older Morgan sequence could
be included the home release of the film.
The final goodie tucked into the Avengers:
Endgame re-release that Marvel has confirmed
is a "special sneak peek" at the next MCU
movie, Spider-Man: Far From Home, due out
in theaters on July 2nd.
Bringing Endgame back into theaters just days
before Far From Home opens is a risky move,
since fans could overlook the Spidey sequel
in favor of seeing Endgame again.
Thankfully, it looks like Marvel is using
the re-release as a way to boost hype for
Peter Parker's second MCU solo outing.
However, an introduction clip, a deleted scene,
a Spider-Man: Far From Home tease, and a tribute
montage may not be enough to attract viewers.
That could pose a problem since it appears
that Marvel's main reason for re-releasing
Avengers: Endgame is to earn enough money
to beat out Avatar and become the biggest
movie of all time.
At least those who do decide to give Endgame
another watch won't leave the cinema empty-handed;
re-release attendees will receive an exclusive
Avengers poster in select theaters while supplies
last.
Catch the Avengers: Endgame re-release starting
on Friday, June 28th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.